hello hello everybody and welcome to a
stock live
my name is rebecca kozak and i am going
to be your host for the next two hours i
am joined with my amazing co-hosts who
help make this whole program run
smoothly with jonty mccollier our also
the website master of askdoclive.com
we have
nasima omar and ruth ellen sanchez all
helping and for those of you who are on
live with us make sure you check out the
chat i know if you don't know it's there
you're not going to see all of the
helpful information that ruth ellen and
nasima are putting in that chat but if
you are watching the replay that's okay
you can get with the person that invited
you to this program and they will
provide information on how to get the
products that you are needing to help
you obtain optimal health
now in this program
it is to provide educational information
only on the importance of nutrition and
supplementation in a world where the
food supply is empty and void of what
the body needs not just to survive but
to thrive and in this program we'll be
sharing those nutritional options that
we have found
to be the most absorbable
and used by the body that actually help
give results they can be absorbed they
can be utilized and the best part about
it the man who put the research into
most of the formulations of these
products is here with us today
now the fda requires us to let you know
that our products are not meant to treat
prevent diagnose or cure any diseases
and this program is not meant to take
the place of your primary care physician
but we bring you good news the genetic
theory has been proven incorrect and
through the science of epigenetics which
is the study of how your behaviors and
environment can change the way that your
dna works
it's epigenetics empowers you the
individual to take control
and you have more control than you think
and we're going to be providing
information for you today to help you
take control and to guide us
we are absolutely honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics
dr joel
wallach dr wallach
welcome to aztalk live
well thank you so much for the kind
introduction rebecca and thank you for
the entire team and good morning entire
team
and
you know you know we have lots of stuff
going on and uh
it's you know the information
is um
very useful in saving yourself let's
just start there
um what i want to talk about today
is
the false information that drives us in
the wrong direction
which cost us
25 to 50 years of our life if you do
everything right
you'll add 25 to 50 healthful years your
life why would you not want to spend 25
to 50 more years with people you love
why would you not want to spend 25 to 50
more years doing the things you love to
do
it doesn't take much effort but it does
take
awareness i think that's probably
important here it does take awareness
um when you look at this morning's
figures
uh from the coven i hate to keep
dwelling on that
um but it's it's a fact
and when you look at this morning's
figures on covid coven
as of this morning
early we had 741
898 dead
now what does that mean 741 898 dead
that's in 18 months
now in two years 1918
1919 and the spanish flu in america we
had 675 000 dead
subtract 675 000 from 741 thousand eight
hundred ninety eight he had sixty six
thousand eight hundred ninety eight
almost 67 000 more dead
in 18 months than we had in two years
during the spanish flu
all right there's a problem here
and um
we had vaccinations
uh earlier than they had in the spanish
flu
well the medical system
banked the survival of america back
your survival the survival of your
relatives your loved ones your teammates
your church mates and temple mates and
all this kind of stuff
doctors bet everything
everything on vaccinations
well
vaccinations today aren't working as
good as they did in 1797 when edward
jenner came up with the first
vaccination which was for our smallpox
and he noticed that the milkmaids had
the cow pox on their hands and they
never got smallpox they were the ones
who always survived because they never
got
and so he took one of his
farmhands sons who was nine years old
scratched him put some of that pus from
the milkmaids
cow pox into those scratches and a
couple months later when these smallpox
came through their farm village
that kid was one of the few kids that
didn't get smallpox
and so that was the beginning of
vaccinations that was edward jenner a
little country doctor in england
in
um
1797.
well today we're not doing very well
okay we're doing very well
when it comes to vaccinations we're
getting all these breakthrough
infections
even
one of our u.s supreme court judges
see he
got a breakthrough infection
um kavanaugh brett kavanaugh
he had two you know in
vaccinations a month apart
and i thought he was in good shape and
he wound up with covid
and so he can't be in there he's got to
vote remotely because he can't be with
all the other judges and pass on the
copa to them
and so we have
um in our hospitals there's so many
people in the hospitals now with covet
despite the vaccinations uh they have to
rent vans and that sort of stuff
to put people in because they don't have
enough beds in the hospitals ninety
three percent of the people in the
hospitals are unvaccinated thirty five
percent are kids under the age of twelve
now because the kids infections are
going up and up and up and up and up
very rapidly
because they are thought to be sort of
more immune to it
but not really
well let's um look at and see why let's
look at let's compare us with india this
is this morning's figures from india
they have 1.3
billion people they have five times the
population we do we have 332 million
they have 1.3 billion
they have 34 million 41 000 um
and see here 691 infections we have 45
million 639
um thousand
infections okay so we have about 11
million more infections than they do in
india despite them having five times the
population we have seven hundred forty
one thousand eight hundred ninety eight
dead they only have four hundred fifty
one thousand nine hundred six dead we
have three hundred thousand more dead
than they have so what's going on here
well it's a diet thing it's a diet thing
it has to do with
um
and they don't have nearly the
percentage of vaccinated people as we do
and so it's a bad thing we got to go
back over 100 years ago
again
um you appreciate
that for a hundred years
england
occupied the northern nine states of
india for over a hundred years
and this was to draft all their young
boys so they could fight the english
wars all over the world so they didn't
have to draft the english boys they
drafted the indian boys okay
and
um
they also
in addition
to
occupying
the northern united states
the english taught the people in those
nine northern states to grow wheat
barley around oats to eat and drink
wheat butter and oats whereas the
southern 20 states and the seven
territories of indian
they only have five percent of the
deaths in the northern states they have
95 percent of the deaths and the
southern states they have a uh excuse me
in the southern states they have 17
percent of the infections in the
northern states where the where they um
english occupied them for a hundred
years they have
uh let's see here
uh it's like uh
87 of the infections
and so
why is it so different they're
homogeneous people it's not like us we
have 50 different countries here in
in
usa with all the people from all these
other
immigrants coming in from all these
other countries and diets and lifestyles
and all this kind of stuff in india
they're very homogenous but that
northern nine states where they were the
english occupied for a hundred years
they just live on wheat butter and oats
in the south they eat like asians eat
rice and corn
and um sweet potatoes
and of course they
eat a lot of beans and squash and
seaweed where they don't do that in the
north and so that's why there's this
vast difference in rate of infections of
deaths between the northern united
states and the southern 20 states and
seven territories in india well we need
to take a a lesson from that okay
we need to eat like asians and stop
eating like the english stop eating like
the europeans
and when you look at it
let's look at the next series of figures
let's look at the average lifespans
which is a great way to
evaluate how successful people are
remember we rank 48th in the world when
it comes to longevity there's 47 other
countries this is from
the cdc our center for disease control
and the world health organization this
is the most recent figures we rank 48th
in the world when it comes to longevity
there's 47 other countries whose peoples
live longer than us
we've got the best medical system in the
world
that's not true
okay we rank 47th
excuse me 48th in the world when it
comes to
uh longevity when it comes to this is
one that freaked me out when it comes to
infant mortality when it comes to saving
our kids from dying
before two years of age
we rank 29th in the world
there's 28 countries who do better of
taking care of their babies than we do
somebody needs to go to jail here okay
this is terrible terrible terrible
information again from the cdc and the
world health organization this is the
most recent stuff now let's look at
um
japan
their average lifespan is 84.
our average lifespan is 75. they live
nine years longer than we do and of
course the human life expectancy is 155.
uh when you look at the philippines
their average lifespan is 69.6
and
so they're not doing very good they're
they're leaving 85 years on the table
australia their average lifespan is 83.
um
they live they live um eight years
longer than we do we look at the new
zealand they live in 82 they live seven
years longer than we do you look at the
uk our parent country who eats nothing
but wheat bread i know they live to be
eighty-one he lives six years longer
than we do
and uh let's see here
oh in hunza they're the longest live
culture
on earth they're a little country that
primarily in the shangri-la valley
between halfway between pakistan and
china
and there was a book in 1929 written
about the lost horizon and a movie that
came out in 1933 which was the movie of
the book lost verizon was written by
james hilton who is a new york times and
london times investigative reporter
there was his doctor running around
um between pakistan and china and europe
by the name of lee chen yun
and he was claiming to be 180 years old
and selling his herbs he says if you
take my herbs you'll love to be 180 like
me and blah blah blah blah
and so
the new york times london times sent
james hilton to follow this guy and see
if he was a charlatan and a crook and
fake and all kind of stuff and he found
him for almost two years and he said
this guy is real
because he checked every place he was
for you know the last 150 years and so
forth you that was him okay and he had
photographs of him as soon as the
cameras were available and everything
so he came up
and made a book and a movie out of it
lost horizon
and um
the the people and huns that are still
there their average lifespan is 120. and
when you look at
their
longevity
okay the longest lived ones lived to be
165 160 870 that kind of stuff almost
like lee shin yun
and um that's because they live near
this glacier
uh the gilgit glacier and it grinds up
all the rocks and the canyons it comes
through
and so forth
now when you look at
india they're very interest india is
very interesting
their average lifespan is 70 okay so we
live five years longer than them but
there's another piece here to the indian
story
um
uh in india
uh they uh
um have
uh a the arabian sea which is on their
southern border kind of like the gulf of
mexico is with us okay so the arabian
sea is to india as the gulf of mexico is
the usa
and
they have the worst record
in the world when it comes to dead zones
they have sixty six thousand seven
hundred square miles of dead zones in
the arabian sea
and so i asked siri i just asked siri
hey siri does india have any glaciers
because it's the marines
okay
um
the little dams in front of the glaciers
that you know are made from silt and
sand and gravel and all kinds of stuff
the blocker re-redirect the food to the
algae which is required to make oxygen
now i looked at it and all these mass
die offs going back two billion years
ago i would say going back two billion
years ago the man we know this from
fossils and all this kind of stuff
these mass styles thousands and
thousands of species the trilobites
alone had 25 000 different species of
trilobites and they were around for 100
million years they're the most
successful of all organisms ever living
on earth they're trilobites
but they went away 100 000 years they
all died out
and then here's all these empty valleys
now because all these animals all these
thousands of species died and dinosaurs
are looking oh my gosh look at that look
at all these empty valleys so they moved
down into those valleys and that's when
the dinosaurs all died out over the next
hundred thousand years because they're
in those same valleys that had the same
glaciers
okay because the glaciers were damping
up the foods and so the the algae could
not make oxygen every time there was a
mass die off some species of animals
died and there was 12
sort of pre-humans that came along and
between them they lasted a couple
hundred million years
okay but they all died out and they all
died out during ages of glaciation when
the glaciers were there
so what is it about glaciers well they
dam up the food supply to the green
plants
and one of the big ones happened 400
million years ago
when the glaciers
cut off the food supply to all the
swamps in north america and europe
okay and so all the algae died and 83 of
all coal
is made from that dead algae
and 17 percent
is made from dead peat moss
all from ages of glaciation well when i
asked siri how many glaciers are there i
never thought about glaciers in india is
there any glaciers in india they said
and siri said there's ten thousand
glaciers in india what
are these active glaciers
siri yes there's ten thousand active
glaciers in
india right now
and they added they threw in sort of as
a sub
thing they said oh and by the way they
have at least two
marines per glacier some have three and
four marines per glacier so they have
twenty thousand marines twenty thousand
dams damming up the food supply
in those big rivers in india which were
taking the minerals into
the arabian sea and that's why the
arabian sea is dying and has a big dead
zone
and so it began to make sense
well the same thing is true of the reef
dying reefs are sort of a little
mountain inside of a dead zone
and they require two organisms to
maintain themselves
algae and polyps
okay
we're talking about
these
polyps make and maintain
the
um reefs they take the minerals out of
the ocean water and turn them into this
sort of
a hard limestone reef
and but they require an enormous amount
of oxygen
and this is why they love the algae and
they make little holes for the algae to
grow in so they'll produce the oxygen
for the polyps
okay to actually make and maintain the
reefs
this is two organism community
well when you shut off the food supply
to the algae with
dams human-made dams like we did in the
mississippi river
and the missouri river and all the
tributaries we shut off the food supply
to the algae in the gulf of mexico and
that's why we have a dead zone in the
gulf of mexico well in india
they have these 10 000 glaciers but they
also have several hundred
thousand dams
in
india
for water control um irrigation
uh hydroelectric and all this kind of
stuff
and so they shut off the food supply
to the arabian sea and that's why they
have the biggest
um because they have ten thousand
glaciers and ten 000 dams
okay isn't that crazy and so once you
look at this it all makes sense
and it's no mystery
and so it's not pollution it's not
global warming and so i have a new cd
out
i'm working on the book now
the cd
actually have two new cds
the cd for the subject here
is dr wallach's laws of photosynthetic
disruption and global warming
what i'm saying here is that all the
mass die offs
occurred because of
um of um
dams of one kind or another either
man-made dams but the priority most of
them 85-90
of all the mass die-offs
were caused by
the dams that were caused by glaciers
the moraines
and once i figured that out it just
began it's okay well how many
how many glaciers does this country have
how many glaciers in this country and it
just all came together so anyway this
um cd goes into this history
uh because i had to look up all the
information for the book so i also put
it into a cd which i did
um dr wallach's laws of photosynthetic
disruption global warming pollution has
nothing to do with it i repeat that
pollution has nothing to do with it
and
global warming because of carbon dioxide
has nothing to do with it fossil fuels
have nothing to do with how many cars
were there 100 million years ago how
many cars were there 400 million years
ago how many cars were there two billion
years ago none none none none so that's
a crapola theory if i can use that
french word okay
and so
it's one of those things where this is
not difficult now the next one
um i actually gave a lecture it was
actually a zoom
uh with scott ferdulis in the um
philippines and he was very clever he
forwarded that zoom to eight asian
countries which he has a lot of business
in including
china and japan and
um
taiwan
singapore
hong kong those kind of places right
and i was speaking to millions of people
when i was doing that zoom was just
crazy well so he actually
recorded it
uh and edited it and everything and made
a wonderful cd called the manchurian
prescription a brainwashing prescription
i don't know if you know the stories of
the manchurians they go back hundreds of
years maybe thousands of years but
they're always sort of a devious bunch
okay
uh
you know they're kind of like an
anti-government political party and
they're always causing problems to the
chinese government
manchurian you've heard of the movie the
manchurian candidate
okay
based on the same principle
well i didn't know this
but
when he
edited my talk which is for about an
hour long
he left he let me speak
on the recording for say two three
minutes and then he would put it in
mandarin for two or three minutes put me
on for two or three minutes they put
mandarin for treatments me for two or
three minutes to mandarin for treatment
so yes it would be an hour it's a two
hour long thing but it's a mix of
english and chinese okay so anybody who
wants to have a business in chinatown
or chinese acupuncture clinic
or a chinese school
or
any of the chinese restaurants in any
big city
around the world
they need to get this cd and use that
to encourage them to join us in
youngevity and get the information
because these these small chinese
communities
in europe and united states and
chinatowns are dying
okay because people don't have the money
to go out and eat and pay for parking
and all this kind of stuff
and so they're being impacted
uh more than some place like mcdonald's
so to speak you understand what i'm
saying because it's more expensive to
eat a chinese restaurant which everybody
like to do say once a week or once a
month or something like that but now
they're all closing down because there's
no traffic
well as somebody
is interested they need to take this
manchurian
um
let's see here the manchurian
prescription
and take this
and put you know the little sticky thing
on there with their phone number on it
their id number
and sit and talk to these people and
listen to a couple of minutes with it
maybe 10-15 minutes and show them how it
works and so on
and believe me they will listen to it
because it's in chinese
and um
we will be able to encourage
a growth sector in youngevity in the
chinese community which we haven't been
able to do yet well now is our time
because they are being hit real hard by
this pandemic is very very bad
okay so with that um let's see here i'm
going to turn this over to you and we
can start taking some questions or i can
answer some you know other issues for
you
thank you so much dr wallach it's always
good to know what's going on around the
world and how
things are affected and so i really find
it interesting that you know
millions billions years ago
when you cut off the mineral flow
everything downstream
died it died
yeah it does it just doesn't thrive and
for us
you know our food supply has been cut
off from that mineral flow
which affects us personally because it's
not in our food
and
it's the people just don't get it they
think oh well i eat organic i eat clean
or i eat raw well let me let me
interject in there um have you ever
heard of four food groups
yes
that's the biggest killer in the world
right now oh i eat the four food groups
i eat well
okay
well there you go
uh because plants only need three
elements from the soil npk nitrogen
phosphate stands and when you look at
the analysis of all commercial
fertilizer all they have in them is npk
okay
um and so it's one of those things where
when you look at it
we're in trouble because of npk because
plants don't have the nutrients they
used to have in them
and it all and i forgot to say this it
all came about
because of electricity
uh prior to three o'clock in the
afternoon monday september 4th 1882 on
pearl street in new york city in the
bluff overlooking the construction of
the brooklyn bridge
okay
um we were using wood for fuel in our
wood stoves and our fireplaces fire pits
outside
light and you name it we we're using
wood for fuel and and uh
straw and uh
coal and all kinds of stuff
for fuel
and
um
the ashes we put into the garden now the
ashes had minerals in it they were in
the algae and in the um wood and all
that kind of stuff because trees and
algae would suck up all these minerals
when you burn them the ashes were 95
minerals and only five percent carbon
okay if the really good wood ashes
are snow white they're not black or gray
or anything like that there's no white
because all the carbon had been burnt
out of them okay
but they have whatever minerals the tree
sucked up now do you think the sequoia
trees only sucked up three minerals no
they needed 20 nutrients
for
the um
uh photosynthesis to take place 20
nutrients uh you can have plenty of sun
and plenty of chlorophyll but without
those 20 nutrients you're not going to
get
photosynthesis those trees those sequoia
trees
you know they're like
small ones or three tons big ones are 30
tons i mean these are huge places
where'd that wood come from all that
wood came from the carbon dioxide in the
air the leaves in those trees starting
with their little bitty baby ones you
know six inches tall they're converting
carbon dioxide into wood
that's where all the wood and trees
comes from
okay got it well those trees suck up all
these minerals out of the soil because
because the chlorophyll and chloroplasts
needed those minerals
okay to convert carbon dioxide into wood
and into oxygen
isn't it crazy
well it's
yeah it's i i think that it's super
fascinating because when you think about
a tree everything that's above
kind of resembles with down under and it
goes down deep
and the nice thing about the trees and
the plants is they can actually absorb
those
metallic minerals
converting them into a form that we can
actually utilize
and putting that ash out into the
wherever the food is growing
is going to be replenishing that top
soil because i think
i did a lot of a lot i've done a lot of
driving dr wallach over the last week
and
to see you know thousands and thousands
of acres
that have been planted
i it's i'm trying to visualize okay how
are those minerals that that food that
that plant is taking out of the ground
being
you know replenished
yeah and are they making oxygen see if
they're getting all 20 nutrients they'd
be making oxygen if they're only getting
three nutrients they're not making
oxygen anymore
right and and it can be in the ground
but it's going to be depleted because
it's continually being sucked out
so
i and and i just
i mean i personally have felt the
effects
of what it feels like to be sick and
mineral deficient
and then to get the minerals flooding
into my body
and how fabulous it is
it's like
adding life
just
you know it's welcome it's wonderful dr
wily
and the fact that you
um you know discovered this at such a
young age
and had nine years old that was nine
yeah
yes and you've just made it your life
passion to make sure that people get
this information
i just
it it blows me away because you've come
up a lot come up against a lot of
hurdles
a lot of people not agreeing with you
and yeah
well some of them are pretty dramatic
you know i found the cause prevention
cure of cystic fibrosis and they fired
me from the european primate center well
that's a genetic disease no no it's not
here's all the evidence they fired me
and that's when i went back to school
and became a physician and then uh i
learned how to prevent and cure
um muscular dystrophy i know i'm not
supposed to use that word but it's true
i know how to prevent and cure take me
to court i'd love to be on a front page
on a court thing let them pay for the
advertising right but anyway um
muscular dystrophy is very easy disease
to to prevent and cure
and then i'm the guy who also got rid of
sudden death syndromes i can prevent
i can't cure it because they're dead i
can prevent sediment death syndrome it's
such as hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
heart disease and it's not the mother's
laying on the babies ninety percent of
the babies that were diagnosed with
centimeter syndrome were dead in their
cribs and the mother wasn't in the crib
with the baby when they died okay
and so um this is
i i i i'm the guy who discovered the
cause prevention and cure of cystic
fibrosis as much as me i'm the guy who
found the cause and prevention of
sediment death syndrome and i haven't
had one medical school one naturopathic
school one veterinary school
one pharmacy school one nursing school i
haven't had one of them say why don't
you come give us a lecture on this
i've done it for free
yeah yeah
it's criminal it's criminal what they're
trying to do is protect their issues
because
the first thing they teach medical
students
in pre-med in medical school
is
if you cure a patient you lose a
customer
it's the first thing out of the
instructor's mouth what you want to do
is maintain them and treat their
symptoms and make them happy
and that way they'll be happy for 20 30
years if you give them the cure they
won't do it
and so you have to be smarter than the
patient don't give them the cure give
them something that's going to keep
their pain away and then they'll stick
with it
and that's where i was dr wallace they
had given up they said that there was
nothing that could be done um other than
manage pain
because it well surgery terrified me i
saw what it did to my aunt there was
absolutely no way i was going down that
road well see you're smarter than
average beer
so
yeah but
i just i
i encourage everybody here today with us
dr wallach to share this program with
somebody that you love
and if all of us could start sharing
this information
then
i just see a tidal wave
of better health
absolutely
it's fabulous i mean because you
you can't put garbage in and expect
you know a fantastic diamond to come out
yeah
but when you put these minerals into the
body
and give the body what was
what needed by design
uh the design just works so smooth so
fabulous it goes up
you know you feel younger
yeah we'll give we'll give god all the
credit and god made remarkable organisms
and he
built them in such a way they could be
self-renewing and all this and the other
and it's we that screw it up
yeah
well because think about it dr while if
we start from like this tiny little
cell
that's an egg and you can't see it
yeah you can't even see it it develops
into what we are here today and we're
continually regenerating so as we
continually regenerate
depending on the fuel that those cells
have when they're regenerating
determines the outcome yeah well good
vision
yeah well good visual rebecca is an egg
a chicken egg or a duck egg either one
and you crack that egg open raw now on
top of the yolk is this little white dot
about the millimeter in diameter right
that's the chick
you can take that chick off and
everything in that yolk and the white of
the egg is nothing but nutrition
now in that egg in 21 days
that little chick that's a millimeter in
diameter
will eat all that yolk and all the white
of the egg and make a heart and a liver
and a kidney and a brain
and blood vessels and
muscles and bones and lungs and all the
thyroid glands and adrenal glands and
testicles ovaries all from that
yolk and the and the
white of the egg anybody who says oh
those eggs will kill you if you eat eggs
didn't kill that chick in 21 days
just think of how remarkable that is you
take an organism there's two cells
uh it's grown to multi hundreds of cells
or thousands of cells it's a millimeter
in diameter and in 21 days it eats all
of that yolk and white in the egg and
becomes a chick with all these organs
and tissues
and function eyes and everything from
all the nutrition and an egg you can't
tell me that an egg is bad
no when something
when it goes from an egg to full life
breathing walking reproducing
how can that be bad
and it's natural it's not me
i just correct
it
yeah it's so fascinating and i hope that
all of you here with us
get it
or help somebody else get it
that you know processed foods
where they take all the nutrients out
and then throw some stuff together make
it quick and easy
you're not getting the nutrition that
your body needs
so i really really encourage you to help
people see the light and understanding
that
nutrition is so important if you want a
better tomorrow
and the food doesn't have it so you have
to supplement when you hit this you hit
the secret right on the head here um
rebecca you have to eat well avoid the
bad foods all the inflammatory foods and
all the bad foods
glutens they can absorb the nutrients
absorb you know
avoid gluten
and then you need to take the 90th cents
nutrients just that's health insurance
just think of the 90 essential nutrients
as health insurance because you're
guaranteeing you're going to get the
nutrients you need because if you're
just eating the four food groups and
eating well
you can't guarantee that because the
farmer gets paid not by how much
nutrition's in the food the farmer gets
paid by tons and bushels per acre so he
just wants the cheapest way to get those
tons of bushels which is npk
and then his livestock his cows and
sheep and pigs and chickens and and so
forth he gives all the vitamins and
minerals to
because he knows there's nothing in the
wheat barley and oats
because he only put npk in them
yeah yeah and we need more than mpk
folks that's nitrogen phosphorus and
potassium we need so much more
and not in a metallic form
because you know some of those metals
that are having
you know they can be toxic we need it in
a form that the body can actually
utilize
and
and feed
so
i just dr welling
the longevity products
and how they're formulated the raw
ingredients go into the uncompromised
quality that goes into them
i know sometimes if if you compromise on
quality then yeah you're going to have
your flow of inventory and you're not
going to have any breaks but whenever
you are so
adamant about making sure those raw
ingredients are quality
then
you know yeah there's going to be yeah
we do not settle for anything
we do not settle for anything less
rebecca than perfect
well and i think everybody needs to
realize
they deserve that dr wally everybody
deserves perfect
it's
yeah so when you think about it okay is
your health worth
three five ten dollars a day
i would say yeah an extra 25 50 years
absolutely
yeah
yeah it was you know when i was talking
with an individual they're looking at a
procedure that's going to cost 160 000
and it's something dr wallach that you
have worked with people i've worked with
people they've completely overcome it
for four hundred dollars a month
and
it it's just it blows me away that they
would be willing to
to spend so much money on a procedure
that um isn't gonna address the
underlying cause yeah well see that's
why
actually health insurance is one of the
worst things for human health
because people say well i can do
whatever i want because if i get sick
you know health insurance will pay for
it
that is a common attitude and don't
worry about
you know um this procedure is a hundred
thousand dollars but don't worry about
it because insurance will pay for it
okay let's do it
you don't even think of it for 30
seconds you don't even think was there
another way to do this without the
surgery
because insurance will pay for the
yeah
wow
i'm so thankful that you know i had
surgery i just said no
i mean even though i had sorry
insurance i just said no
and and i'm so thankful for that because
i don't need it
i would i was able to use the
supplementation dr wallock that you put
together that you recommended
and
and now
i have no limitations and i just i thank
you for that i thank god
for putting you here on earth
and giving you the wisdom and the
forethought
and i thank you dr wallach for using the
gift that you were given to gift and
benefit and bless the rest of us so
thank you thank you thank you
well thank you again for all the kind
words and again i give god all the
credit
and why he chose me to figure all this
out and at least understand what he was
trying to tell me
uh i don't know why but he chose me and
so i'm very thankful and i feel
responsible and that's why i work so
hard
yeah well and we appreciate your work is
not going in vain that's for sure
oh
well thank you everybody again you are
watching ask doc live this program is
being brought to you by askdoclife.com
so if you were finding this on your own
nobody shared this program with you you
have not spoken to anybody ever ever
about youngevity or dr wallach or the
products
that
we will be talking about today then feel
free to go to
askdoclive.com
they can get these cds from you too
right cds and books and things yes so we
have we have your most popular
publications on our website
um for the a lot of the cds and and the
multi-packs you want to go to
drjwalik.com
and you'll find all of dr wallach's
publications there directly from his
distribution
so
lots of fabulous stuff dr well like i i
love it and i love the fact that
for those of you who are distributors
and want to use
the publications to do the talking for
you these cds are fabulous and you can
even pay a little bit extra and have
your information put right on that cd
ready to hand out and ready to go
now dr wallach
i think that we need to go to the first
hand okay let's go let's do it all right
so the first guest that we have with us
today i'm going to go ahead and get him
to unmute is robert
robert
go ahead and unmute yourself you are on
live with dr wellick
hello i'm looking for my camera button
let's see
okay robert how can we help you sir
i've been on your program for uh keto
weight loss lost 20 pounds thank you
thanks for the testimony
lost 20
yeah uh still working on losing my gut
so i could do some help there but i got
my blood uh
my no my hair analysis back
it's high in arsenic and maybe that
arsenic is affecting my health so i'm
wondering what to do about that okay how
much you weigh robert
okay and how old are you
okay
six
i'm sorry
you're 68
66 i'm 66 okay and then um see how how
tall are you
five nine
okay do you have any um varicose veins
spider veins or hemorrhoids
i do not
okay the reason why i'm asking you have
some dashing white hair that makes you
look like is sage
right yes a lot you know people who have
white hair say oh he's got a lot of
experience it's blonde all my life i
think it's starting to get darker with
being on your program okay yeah you
should see
an increase in color um
how long have you been on the program
uh more than six months okay
and yeah you should be seeing uh color
coming back in your hair especially if
you're really i mean adamant about
avoiding wheat by rhinos gluten so you
can maximize absorption gray hair is not
due to age gray hair um spider veins
vertical hospital hemorrhoids are due to
the same deficiency
um that causes gray hair and also
ruptured aneurysms in the brain and the
heart and
and the ar and so forth so
white grain silver hair is a red warning
light you need to pay attention to
and so
um
i'm going to you know say what you
should be taking here
um do you have any other issues any
diabetes or hybrid pressure arthritis
anything like that
low thyroid
thyroid okay
fatigue
and fatigue
okay
[Music]
all right
um do you have any idea where you might
be getting arsenic from
uh salmon
uh maybe uh seaweed mushrooms no no no
no do you eat fruit
uh i've been off fruit for this keto
diet uh i do
did you eat fruit before the keto diet
yeah i grow my own fruit
okay well one of the things you find in
um
uh insecticides that they put on
uh fruit trees and fruit you know
everything from
pumpkins
to
oranges and apples and bananas and
pomegranates and things like that
many of the especially in the european
countries in the third world
the insecticides for fruit trees contain
arsenic
and so when you're eating fruit from you
know that are imported from foreign
places you're getting arsenic that's
where you're getting the arsenic from
so well my my trees all my stuff on my
property is organic i don't put spray on
anything so you never eat any food that
you don't grow
uh boy some of it but i buy the organic
stuff
it doesn't matter
they have neighbors
and this tree sucks it up from the
underground water
because of their neighbors okay you're
getting it from somewhere
so here we go
um 148 pounds once you get rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat no brother and oats no sugar no
carbohydrates even the diet one's got to
go
i want you to
uh also take two healthy brain and heart
pattern month the full dose everything
twice a day two healthy brain and heart
factor month has 215 nutrients including
the base of the
healthy start pack which is the original
90 essential nutrients
plus all the other new ones
and then i want you to get our msm
take three of those three times a day uh
that'll be two vowels a month they will
support and promote maintenance repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue disc between vertebrae bone
breaks your bone itself and also uh help
your your body work of to make the
thyroid happy and then for the thyroid
gland once you take three of our fucoid
z capsules twice a day that's two
bottles a month um
the fucoid z is made from eight or nine
different algaes from the ocean
and then i want you to take three of our
oceans gold twice a day that's two
bowels a month that's from the other
ocean
and they have eight or nine different
algaes in there from the other ocean
and this usually within weeks the
thyroid gland really kicks in and starts
working properly
and because not only you know you're
probably not getting the things that all
the thyroid needs as well as the arsenic
which can be a negative for the thyroid
and so
one of my first scientific papers
was written on a mass die-off that was
caused by pollution dealing with the
thyroid gland
and so that was my first scientific
paper written it was dealt with 500
dead
okay and so um that's what got the 25
million dollar grant which i did my 20
000 autopsies on
to you know be one of the founders of
the science of epigenetics
so if you do all that
um
let's start there uh and for for energy
i want you to use our rebound or sports
drink
it comes
in sticks individual servings we've got
30 individual servings in a box it comes
in canisters
with a scoop and it also comes in cans
uh guy your weight you can have two
highway 142 and i have two servings a
day
of the
um rebound it was actually made for
olympic athletes and professional
athletes i mean tens of thousands of
athletes all over the world use this
rebound thing for energy because it's
not just sugar
water or carrot caffeine it has a
hundred nutrients and it's 75 78
minerals
and also 25 vitamins amino acids
so this is something that you want to
add to your program
um
and so that covers the thyroid that
covers your your body's needs
including your liver and your kidney and
oh do you have any high blood pressure
or kidney issues
i do not okay good all right let's go
with that call us every couple of weeks
because you know your issues are red
warning lights and my concern is you
know that the same things that cause
white grains over here varicose veins
spider veins that kind of stuff
also
um causes ruptured aneurysms in the
brain coronary arteries and ulcers and
also
oh again
my echo
echo echo echo okay thank you john t
um any rate uh so this is gotta get rid
of bad stuff take all the good stuff and
within weeks you're gonna notice a huge
positive difference but you gotta stay
away from the bad stuff everybody in
your family you cannot be anybody in
your household um
loved ones roommates and nobody can be
eating gluten because you'll get
cross-contaminated in the laundry and
also on the food preparation surfaces
and couches where people watch tv and
the rugs and the beds and all that kind
of stuff
and so you really really really have to
watch the gluten issue
okay back to you rebecca
all right dr wellick and hope i'm not
the cause of that echo um
but sonia is
so sonya wrote in the chat she's been in
her supplementation she's
and her insomnia is getting better i
know sleep is a problem that so many
people have an issue with and not
getting enough sleep not to fall asleep
or
stay asleep but she has um something
that's working on and
it's a
is a keloid scar
from
um
after having a breast removed
from cancer
she wants to know what she can do
to help get rid of the scar or or less
in it okay sure she's sure here i'm
still getting this thing
okay i will turn myself off this minute
and let you go ahead so um she's five
foot seven seventy kilograms
and i don't know exact weight there's
about a hundred which is about a hundred
that's about 150 pounds
and she's how tall
he's five foot seven
and she's 60 years old
okay
all right
well we just wish her all the best for
the for the breast cancer issue we'll
keep our fingers crossed there but in
the meantime she needs to get rid of all
the bad stuff all the fried foods all
the processed meats all the oils all the
glutens we brought around oats uh all
the sugar on the carbonated drinks all
the things that gave her cancer she's
got to get rid of okay
then at 150 pounds i want her and that's
about right for five foot seven for a
lady i want her
to take
excuse me
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month
uh two full doses a day okay
um a
full dose of breakfast and full those
dinner time that's two full you know two
full doses a day
and then i wanted her to have uh two
bottles of msm so you can take three
breakfast through the lunch free dinner
time they're to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
two-thirds of the skin is made out of
connective tissue
and so this is why i like to use msm for
scars
and injuries and burns and all kinds of
stuff in the skin
eczema psoriasis uh we need the msm
also
i would like her to have
the um
let's see here i would like her to use
our our cal toddy i'd never take the cal
toddy i started out with one quarter a
month so say a half ounce at breakfast
half ounce of dinner time
and some people are really sensitive to
the magnesium that's in the cal toddy so
if you get diarrhea just cut it
and then just take a quarter of an ounce
twice a day instead of a half ounce
twice a day but start out with a half
ounce twice a day but just maybe five
percent of the people get a little
diarrhea and gas or something because of
the magnesium so you got to cut it a
little bit to begin with until your body
gets used to it
and um but the cal toddy
has
as the name implies calcium vitamin d3
has also
got um collagen in there
i also in addition to taking caltotti i
also take the glucogel i take five of
those twice a day
and you know my skin looks pretty good
for 83 year old guy
i don't have any wrinkles and things
like that i have very little gray hair a
little bit in my mustache
and so
i don't have any highlight pressure
i don't have any varicose veins or
hemorrhoids or anything like that
and so anything that has to do with scar
tissue you want to be using all the
things that support maintenance repair
of connective tissue scar tissue that
kind of stuff
and um
i also hair skin and nails she wants to
get our hair skin and nails you can take
two bottles of that a month take three
of those twice a day and again they're
designed to deal with the skin the hair
and obviously the fingernails and
toenails and then call us every couple
of weeks because she will see a great
great benefit and her story's a very
common one and so her testimony will be
very useful for a lot of people
over to
you awesome thank you so much dr wellick
now next we have coming in through um
email is from stephanie
and she has a client who is a female
49 years old
5 foot 5 inches
188 pounds
and this dear lady had
is in the first stages of coral rectal
it says it was all removed during the
cancer was all removed during surgery
and no need for further treatment
bowels had a leak
when seeing backup and ended up with oh
goodness an iliotomy
it i it's i think it's ilo
in ileotomy which is uh
yep for three months um reversal was on
july and since then she's had a struggle
with severe diarrhea emergency and
frequency
um she did have a
of the sigmoid colon removed
okay she doesn't have much intestines
left she's removing this part and that
part and this part and that part okay
well she's a gluten eater and she's
paying the price
because she's a gluten eater
everybody in your home including the dog
the cockroaches everybody's eating glute
okay
she's got to get gluten out of her life
and out of her family's life she cannot
be a cook in a fast food place
she can't work as a waitress in the
spaghetti factory you understand she's
got i mean she can't even say the word
glue
everything she's got was because of
gluten
no wheat bread around oats no fried
foods no processed meats uh no gluten no
wheat brown rhinos no sugar no
carbonated drinks and then at 188 pounds
i wanted to have two healthy abandoned
heart packs per month two healthy brain
heart packs a month to full load of
everything twice a day i want her to get
two bottles a month for msm so you can
take three with breakfast three with
lunch through dinner time that's gonna
support and promote man's repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue including the intestines and the
colon and so forth
then i also want her to have two
or three of the ultimate enzymes say
five or ten minutes before each meal
uh she's gonna go through a couple of
bottles a month of the ultimate enzymes
and uh so she needs that kind of help
also
and that'll relieve a lot of symptoms
and help her digest food better so she's
going to absorb it more efficiently
because the gluten reduces the
absorption efficiency okay
then i also
want her
to have
let's see here the killer biotic which
is the reishi mushrooms and a half a
dozen other mushrooms support her immune
system which is very important here and
also relieve inflammation and pain
and then i want to take three of those
kilobiotics um at breakfast and three
dinner time there's two bottles a month
i want her to have the cell shield rtq
again support the immune system and
anti-inflammatory so you can take three
of those twice a day that's two bottles
a month
and then the btt 2.0 tablets i want to
take nine a day three at breakfast three
at lunch three dinner time it'll support
the immune system and also
anti-inflammatory doesn't require three
bottles a month
and
she's
she's in real danger here
because all these bad things are
progressing progressively doesn't really
she's not really had any intermission
anywhere along the line or you know like
three years of no problems it's just
continuous problems
and um
uh you know the doctors are you know
using her
um
uh
like a bank account they just keep um
you know uh keep dipping into the funds
okay because she has good insurance
and so we really really really really
need to help her interrupt this bad
cycle because she's gonna have to work
on getting all the bad stuff she's gonna
have to work on taking all the good
stuff
and so when people have ongoing problems
that have to do with diet and
nutritional deficiencies this program
will help them immensely
absolutely and when you've got digestive
issues you're not absorbing
that's correct
we we really want to make sure that you
get rid of everything that's preventing
that absorption so that
the nutrients that you're putting in
your body can actually do what they're
what they're meant to do
and the body can do what it's meant to
do by absorbing the nutrients so
oh goodness my heart goes out to her
um well dr wallach we are at the top of
the go ahead and take five minutes right
now and then we will back with more
questions
so everybody thank you so much for being
here with us on stock live i just want
to remind you
that if you were
referred to this program by somebody
specific
get back with them
and ask the questions hey how do i get
the products that this doctor is talking
about that dr wallach is talking about
that i heard about on a stock live
and they will be able to help you with
directing you to how they get their
products also
now again
if you have
never spoken to anybody you can go to
our store at askdoclive.com
and find all the products that dr
wallach will be mentioning today
please if you hear somebody has similar
conditions similar symptoms that you're
going through
write down what dr walk is saying
because that's gonna be what you you
will probably need as well the body was
designed with specific ingredients
we have to have that foundation
in order to
maintain or regain
what the body is designed to be
so we'll be right back after a short
five minute break don't go away get up
stretch get you something to drink and
stay here with us
i stock live
all right thank you so much everybody
for sticking here with us on askdoc live
and i want to remind you that if you are
watching this live with us and you
missed something that dr wallach is
recommending to somebody you can go to
our website at
askdoclive.com and you will find all of
the replays from all of our programs
since we started in july of 2020
so please
you know listen
and then you can go back to the replay
and write down exactly what dr wallach
has recommended for either yourself
you're on live class or for some
one with conditions that are similar to
yours or someone you love
so this program is a resource that we
want to make sure
people are getting the information that
they need
to
make sure that
you know they're able to function or at
least have the opportunity to function
at optimal capacity
so i
look like i am frozen on my end i don't
know if i am for everybody else but
we're gonna go ahead and keep on going
looks like dr wallach is back with us
dr wallach
you are not you are not frozen oh
fantastic
i just love technology
absolutely love it
um so
now
we had a question come in in the chat dr
wallick
when it comes to digestive issues is
gluten
the only thing that would cause
digestive issues
no no
gluten issues of course are important
for absorption
the
digestion issues
one of the biggest
crimes is doctors tell people not to use
salt because it's bad for the heart
that's absolutely positively not true
okay
doctors kill more people by telling them
not to use salt than the enemy has in
all our waters put together
salt is an essential nutrient sodium
chloride is required by every cell in
your body to function do all their
little biochemistries and everything but
also there's specialized cells in the
walls of your stomach called chief cells
which take
sodium chloride
and make hydrochloric acid in your
stomach to break down proteins into
amino acids so you can absorb them you
can't absorb whole proteins you can only
absorb amino acids
the same way
with absorbing iron and b12
you cannot absorb those things without
stomach acid
so anybody who
is avoiding salt i hear this all the
time you know at restaurants well
you know i don't want any salt on my
food
my doctor says it'll hurt my heart
that's absolutely nonsense this goes
back a couple hundred years ago when
they were starting to get packaged foods
and everything they're getting
congestive heart failure and so forth
and people getting a lot of edema in
their legs
and they figured out that if you
restricted salt for a while uh you get
it would speed up the
loss of the edema in your legs uh it's
bad for your heart so a couple hundred
years ago they started telling people
don't use salt because it's bad for your
heart don't use salt it's bad for your
heart it's just like sudden death
syndrome mothers weren't laying on their
babies
cystic fibrosis wasn't genetic much
history wasn't genetic i mean have you
heard anything from
the telethon
in the last um say 10 15 years about you
know big events to raise money to find
the cause uh and cure for muscular
dystrophy no because i figured it out
a long time ago
okay
and so but they just we're going to
ignore that just just don't say anything
it'll so you know when wallet dies and
we'll discover it
that's the way they they think
okay
and so um
yeah i'm sure there's
how can he still be alive he's 83 years
old
well that's because i don't do the bad
stuff and i take all i take 215
nutrients a day with including the 90
cents on their trips
i've been doing this since i was nine
years old
and so i hope in sort of a roundabout
way but i hope that kind of answers the
question
all right yes i i think that it does dr
wellick thank you so much for that
now let's go ahead and go to the next
hand that is up and we have sam
sam go ahead and uh mute yourself you
are on live with dr walik and before
stamp comes on
i just want to let all of you know what
a fabulous opportunity that we have here
with youngevity and being distributors
um
i am actually on a 4500 mile trip right
now
and i loved the fact that i was able to
meet sam in person
um as part of this trip and just
reconnect with or just connect people
that are like-minded that have this
passion to make sure that
what you have found dr wallach
is being spread as
the truth that's going to help our
nation
our world
find better health so sam go ahead my
friend it was so nice to meet you it was
great to meet you great to see you there
it was a great synchronicity and there
are no accidents remember that no
accidents all right so one thing i want
to say quick and then i'm going to
introduce my client and guest she has a
question for you doc okay so i
personally have been you know following
pretty much what you've been talking
about since your your your tape that i
first heard right
and uh
what i have what i tell people one of
the reasons i'm so healthy is because i
don't go to allopathic doctors unless i
had a trauma are you i mean why would i
want to destroy myself and that's that's
what i'm going to say i've known better
for a long time and now in the last six
months i've been back on
continuously and taken up taking up the
challenge also to work with the help
people
and one of the people i'm helping is my
neighbor here who is really becoming an
advocate
and she has a question her father was a
pharmacist and okay here i am i'm
barbara bennett and i'm wearing my dad's
pharmacy jacket to honor my dad he
practiced pharmacy until he was 90.
all right dr wallach first of all i want
to say thank you because i know you're
very knowledgeable and and that's all i
have to say okay
because i don't want to take somebody
else's time so here i am okay
i've been on youngevity for about six
weeks i had an interruption because i
gave my bottles to somebody else
however i take several medications i'm
going to be real quick i take uh
symbicort amlodipine lamotrigine
gabapentin oxybutine and tramadol for
paint okay
so i
i had a very strange thing happen to me
and maybe you stopped
all you told me was your prescriptions
what diseases do you have
i'm bipolar
that's about
i don't
and i have a little bit high blood
pressure
i have copd
but other than that i'm very very
healthy i'm 74. weigh 186 pounds okay
stop there
yeah stop there a minute
now um
because of the things you said i have to
ask you some follow-up questions here
okay
um
do you have any kidney issues are you on
dialysis
no do you have any diabetes no
do you ever get bounced to hiccups
no okay
uh do you have afib atrial fibrillation
no
do you have tachycardia fast heart rate
or bradycardia slow heart rate no
do you have any joint problems at all
any clickity noises or pain in your
joints i have arthritis i'm taking the
cal tidy
okay
all right
do you have any varicose veins or spider
veins or hemorrhoids
no hemorrhoids but i've had uh
varathena two uh eight varicose veins in
my legs one a week
okay
all right so i i got the picture now
okay did you have something else you
wanted to offer before i
suggested your program
i have a question
okay
about a week and a half ago
i had a very scary episode i was
bouncing against the walls i couldn't
sit down i was calling out names
i was uh
very disoriented the er the paramedic
came he said what week day of the week
because if i don't know
who's the president i said not ronald
reagan i was so disoriented i couldn't
even think and my neighbors were so
concerned okay so they sat with me for a
while the same paramedic came five hours
later i was still out there
and i am asking you this question is it
possible that because my body was
depleted for so many years whatever
and i was taking two capfuls of
everything
and and the omegas which probably don't
make any difference but if i was over uh
giving my body too many vitamins to
think about
okay
okay stop
uh your problem or the five
pharmaceuticals you're taking
okay
okay your your problem or the
pharmaceuticals not your vitamins and
minerals okay okay okay
um i always find it amazing that people
want to blame vitamins and minerals
instead of pharmaceuticals because every
one of those pharmaceuticals has side
effects and you're taking
probably two or three of them that
shouldn't be mixed together
all right what are they
i don't know i'd have to read everything
about them i you know some of those i've
never heard of and it'd take me a week
to figure it all out
so we're not going to do that right now
all right so so sam and i can work on
that
okay but anyway um at 186 pounds i want
you to get rid of all the bad foods
you've heard this before no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no glutens or
wheat products no sugar here are the
notes from your lectures dr wong
stuff
yeah do you if you want me to talk then
you can't keep interrupting me because
otherwise i'm gonna go to somewhere else
you gotta have good manners or i'm gonna
go somewhere else
okay
um
so none of the bad foods then i want you
to take two healthy brain and heart
pattern a month two healthy brain and
heart packs a month the full and sam is
getting all this also okay two healthy
brain hard packs a month to full dose
everything twice a day i want you to get
two bottles a month over msm so you can
take three breakfast street lunch street
dinner time and they're designed to
support and promote maintenance repair
of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue even in the blood
vessels
skin
uh intestines so forth
um i'm one should
also the disc between a vertebrae bone
makes a bone itself and then
i also want you to take our ultimate
daily classic tablet so once you get two
bottles a month there so you can take
three of those twice a day they will
support healthy blood pressure healthy
kidney function
and healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries
also
the copd
is usually a squeezing of the 10th
cranial nerve and the
um
a recurrent branch
recurrent branch of the 10th cranial
nerve by osteoporosis of the skull do
you have any tinnitus or ringing in the
ears or
vertigo or balance problems no
okay good
all right and so then i also uh want you
to take i said the um older daily
classic tablets i want you to take
because of the bipolar i want you to
have our de-stress capsules take three
of those twice is two bowels a month and
they will support healthy brain function
i also want you to get our synaptive get
two bottles of our synaptic and it helps
the brain cells make
the biochemistry necessary for the cell
brain cells to talk to their neighboring
cells and communicate and all go the
same direction i want you to take um i
want you to go ahead and take at least
three of those twice a day it'll be two
vowels a month and the finances are not
a problem i go with three three times a
day that's the synaptive
and that's also the de-stress before
that i also
um let's see here
i'd like you to take um
let's see here
okay let's go with that
i do want you to eat three eggs twice a
day are you on statin drugs at all
no
okay good oh gee three eggs twice a day
they cannot be fried they cannot be
hard-boiled they must be soft
yolks soft boiled soft yolks poached
soft yolk soft soft scrambled butter i
like mine i had mine this morning uh
every morning with you know a soft
scramble and with um
they they actually
uh with butter and they're they're runny
and i've been doing this you know for 80
83 years now
uh no gluten
and all the 90 cents of nutrients plus
my three eggs twice a day
okay okay over to you sam let's start
out with sam sam cool all right quick
question i have so i i i do three eggs
every morning i'm uh i i just drink them
raw and i shake up on a shake with
everything and man is that to me that's
satisfying what do you feel about the
raw eggs stack is your nickname rocky
that's when i first started that when i
was when i first saw that movie so many
years ago i was always powerlifting
lifting weights okay
i've been doing it again now
yeah
okay yeah that's okay as long as you're
taking your supplements because if you
take them with the supplements yeah yeah
yeah okay break them all down
okay
anything else anything else that was it
wasn't that was
appreciate you appreciate okay okay
appreciate you sam appreciate you
barbara get back to me every two weeks
uh let me know what's going on we'll
walk you guys through this but the blood
pressure should go away the copd should
go away and the bipolar should go away
uh this is all very simple stuff
i i don't think i can afford all this
stuff we'll figure it out we'll figure
it out
yeah even if you have to cut the dose
you know take a third take a half
i can't use oxygen so i just won't have
any
okay rebecca who's next well let's let's
not make it
all right dr wallace so next let's go to
the next hand up and it is mike mike go
ahead and unmute yourself please
you are on live with dr wallach
well very good looking forward to it
enjoy the program each week that i'm
able to make it had a lot of trouble in
the last couple of weeks bad audio
couldn't understand it on our end
hopefully it didn't have happened to
yourselves
my bottom i forgot five topical
questions comments from dr wallach if
they would
and they all hand you around
this familiar book
i was looking down show me that familiar
book
this one right here on this oh yeah
doctor while you're cooking without the
bad foods okay gluten
yes
uh just a general comment from your
other observations because i
i listen to your cds your and a lot of
your products i have almost every day
and uh i
occurrence
i live out in the boonies
very isolated and so i take my bricks on
the local tank down and see all the
fisher birds come in and steal my frogs
and what i'm sitting there
we've got squirrels going through the
okay so what
what's your health question
well the health question is the cooking
which uh i was just gonna comment the
squirrel comes down and starts eating
ashes
oh yeah well they're smarter than the
average bear
well i thought you would be amused
because that's the first time i've seen
them do that but i said yeah i think of
dr wallach now past that
with the cookbook i
immediately like to chapters 1 chapters
2 and then i went to eggs and pages
through the eggs which moves me down to
i'm doing my eggs
toast gluten free
on a
cast iron little griddle
which is heavily carbonized and it got
carbonized from burnt fats is that the
wrong surface to be working on
yeah because you're going to get some
inflammatory stuff
so you need to really um get rid of all
that carbonization you know in that um
skillet
or pan or whatever you want to call it
okay
and this is
you need to really clean that puppy up
how about stainless steel instead of
cast iron
stainless steel is fine
okay we'll move to that
then the next thing
in the book it listed uh lord and butter
uh
burn temperatures 380 degrees which i
thought oh super i'm glad to know that
so i
immediately went out and bought this
device which has worked out very well so
infrared thermometer
so i can find out what the temperature
is my my butter that i'm melting it down
with salt because i porch my eggs with
this uh
device
that's easy to access and see how well
i'm cooking my eggs
okay sounds like
your meals are going to be very
scientific that's that's good
and so anyways the eggs are pork
basically in a
very cheap uh steam chamber that i
happened to run across and thought it
was very appropriate so i i like the
cast iron and all that but i figured
what you were going to tell me is get
rid of that carbonized surface
yeah you got to clean it up and of
course you leave it set overnight let's
put some you know put a quarter of an
inch of vinegar in it the vinegar will
kind of
um dissolve a lot of that carbonized
stuff in the skillet
well i agree i use vinegar for cleaning
up rust on
tools
okay that's that's basically me i just
think thank you well i appreciate all
the good thing and i appreciate you
sharing sharing you know your science
approach to the approach to this
well i really well i really like
the thermometer
okay thank you sir
thank you mike
all right so dr wellick next um rhonda
is writing
in the chat about
her daughter-in-law who is 30 years old
three months pregnant
and fell and actually chipped the bone
in her foot
she's wanting to know what can be
recommended for a 30 year old female
three months pregnant
wait a minute she can't be three years
old
years old two months pregnant 33
30 years old okay 30 years
and three months pregnant okay but she
broke her foot so we're wanting to you
know help the human fracture
okay
yeah and she she's 100 and what pounds
i i think she's about 140 pounds if i
remember right
okay yeah well
um she has to decide if she's going to
be breastfeeding that baby or she's
going to use you know a milk replacer if
she's going to be breastfeeding the baby
at three months pregnant the baby's
already farmed
i hope she and praise she's been taking
vitamins and metals for six months
before
she got pregnant
okay
um i i hope she hasn't just been eating
well and not taking supplements before
prior to conception
okay because
um the baby's already formed at this
point
and so you got what you got to this
point okay
so 140 pounds i want her to take start
out with one healthy brain heart pack
per month
um half it does everything twice a day
because not one big hit at one time so
be half of those twice a day of the
ultimate daily
um ultimate daily classic or it's going
to be the healthy brain and heart packs
the health of the brain and heart pack
then i want her to
also
take the de-stress capsules take three
of those twice a day that's two vowels a
month
i also would like her
to
take the
msm take three of those twice as one
bottle a month
and
she can use
you know a little bit of rebound i
wouldn't i wouldn't drink a whole dose
at one time i'd have to drink maybe a 25
percent of a dose of rebound if she
wants something to drink
i wouldn't be drinking soft drinks and
that kind of stuff with all that sugar
in them and juices with all the sugar in
them and so on
and if she doesn't have any other issues
no hybrid pressure no diabetes nor is
right i said people will sharp but we
have secret sauces for you know like 600
different diseases
now when she gets down to
about seven months of pregnancy
and she's you know getting you know
obviously her breasts are beginning to
develop and she's
thinking about breastfeeding then she
needs to increase to two healthy brain
heart packs per month
a full dose everything twice a day
and that's going to help make her milk
with the proper amount of nutrients in
it we don't want that baby we don't want
that baby to have asthma or skin
problems or kidney problems or heart
problems but she went i don't know if
she didn't say if she was taking
prenatal vitamins or any supplements
prior to conception so we don't know
that
okay it's very scary stuff
so anyways
so let's go there and then you know let
us know as she's welcome to ask
questions anywhere along the line
but you know we do need more information
and of course we've given her some place
to start
awesome thank you so much dr wallach
now kiri has questions about
sugars and sugar substitutes
i know removing sugar itself
is part of
you know the good foods bad foods eating
program but there are some things that
call for sugar even in the cookbook so
yes what are your recommendations for
sugar doctor
well i like natural sugars i like honey
i like molasses
that sort of stuff
and
uh
you know we don't have
table sugar you know the white table
sugar within three miles of our house
it doesn't get that close because we
don't want to attract any of the
critters or people who want that stuff
so we keep it far away from oh we're not
gonna go there there's no sugar okay so
that's that's what you want you don't
want any bad guys coming and so you got
to avoid the sugar
um
and
you can actually
eat very well
with a drop or two of honey on something
you're not going to be eating bread
because bread has oh gluten in it
all right
um rice sweet potatoes with butter
uh also uh i like our
um
our pink himalayan salt
has 78 minerals in it now you can put
that i had that this morning on my sweet
potatoes with butter
then my breakfast the pink himalayan
salt and then tonight i'll have it with
dinner
on my i'll have um
again i'll have some wild rice and not
fried but steamed i will also have um
let's see here i'll put butter on that
wild rice along with the pink himalayan
salt
along with a
lamb chops
or a steak
you know i love getting some herbs dr
wallock and mixing it with the butter
and putting it on the steak well yeah
well of course we have we have the
savory division we have all these spices
and stuff like that if you want you want
you want cooking spices
and things you can put on your salads
and stuff like that that don't have
gluten and sugar in them go to our savor
division and it has all this stuff there
so you don't have to be inventing stuff
and running around stores looking for it
you can do it for you know from your
little office in your kitchen or your
little office in your office and you're
at home
this is very easy you know we tried to
cover all bases
and so i'll point you to the our saver
division to look at all the
all of the um
things we have the salad dressings the
sweeteners the salt and so on
yeah we have a we have an amazing
assortment of spices that can be used on
any types of food and it's not just
american food we've got
and in fact i think they were actually
put together down in australia
and they incorporate all different types
of cuisines i think it's absolutely
fabulous fabulous so i encourage you to
look at those as well uh ruth ellen did
you have a question for dr wallach
yes in the chat just came up a question
um that says is brown rice syrup has a
sweetener okay
so i just wanted to make sure since we
were talking about that to include that
yeah brown rice and all his farms are
fine
all right thank you just gotta read the
label just read the label make sure they
haven't added any wheat flour to it
got it
perfect
now let's go to anita who has her hand
up and she was actually the next
question i had so perfect anita
go ahead and unmute
you were on live with dr wallach
hey uh hi dr wallach hi hi
hi
i have a couple of questions and then
one little small one at the end the
first one is about my grandson
um he's 10 years old weighs 63 pounds
and is 4 foot 5. um in march of 2020 he
had
a seizure that lasted about 10 minutes
and they put him on the
effect anyway a seizure drug and he's
been on it ever since he didn't have any
more seizures until last week when he
had another one um he is on beyond tangy
tangerine osteo fx and uh
ultima multi efas
and i was wondering what you would have
to say more okay yeah he he needs a
de-stress capsules
okay i'd have him take two or three of
those twice a day
okay then i would also have him take the
synaptic
he can take two or three of those twice
a day
and
i also want him to take the ultimate
niacin plus one
half of one twice a day
you know break one in half
you have it breakfast have a dinner time
it takes a whole one you might get a hot
flash
okay
um but um
that's that's the direction i would go
and of course don't forget the the 90.
again the um
let's see here say 63 pounds kind of
thing yes yes and so he could you know
he could take a
um
half a dose of the healthy brain and
heart pack a day and cut that in half so
we take a quarter of those twice a day
so that that one healthy brain heart
pack lasting two months
okay at this weight
but he needs some nutrition for that
brain
okay with the selenium in both both of
the
both the aphas
well the slims in the healthy brain
heart pack
yes okay
okay okay
yes
um
my other question is this um
i have
two sons that have dealt with addiction
and one of them has read a book recently
and i think we're going to be hearing a
whole lot more about this but uh
about psychedelic drugs
okay there's been a resurgence in that
is what i'm thinking um
one of my sons that has dealt with
addiction
okay well let me interrupt here um
anytime
what do these kids way are they
overweight
uh these are adult sons 40 43 over white
both over white 41 and 43 both
overweight
both overweight yeah okay well it goes
with the addiction thing
um being overweight
is a nutritional deficiency
and you develop a behavior called pica
just can't stop eating eat you eat and
you eat and you eat and eat
because of these nutritional
deficiencies it drives you to look for
food and you can look it up in any
dictionary pica p-i-c-a just an
insatiable appetite to keep eating even
though you had a 5 000 calorie meal in
15 minutes you want to eat again
after 15 minutes you want to eat again
you're eating 20 meals a day that's why
they're overweight but also
they get tired of eating the same food
and so they try well how about a little
alcohol here i'll have a glass of wine
with my dinner
and well i'm feeling pretty good here so
i might want to have two glasses of wine
a day instead of one and then after a
couple weeks or a couple of months
suddenly now they're addicted and
they're drinking wine all day
okay
because they're still nutritionally
deficient they still haven't dealt with
that
and so these boys need to get on the
keto diet
one meal a day doesn't have to be the
same meal every day one keto bar is
going to take them three boxes there's
only ten bars in a box
they need to take well one keto meal a
day
and then they need per hundred pounds of
body weight one healthy brain heart pack
and
every time they feel like they want to
eat in between meals
they need to
um
have say a shot of a rebound
and you know have a couple of gulps to
rebound
no soft drinks
no sugar no oatmeal for breakfast no
gluten no wheat bread around oats all
that's got to go
bread all that's got to go beer it's all
got to go
um beer is made from gluten except for
rice beer made in certain countries and
so forth
okay and so
all of these addictions go along with
being obese and that all goes along with
being nutritiously deficient which
causes pica which causes constant eating
and that doesn't satisfy them because
they're still looking and looking and
looking but then they get a little
satisfaction when they have some alcohol
either a beer or a glass of wine or a
glass of whiskey or something
and so every hour they're gonna have a
shot of that because it keeps them
sort of level
okay as far as energy goes
but then of course after a couple of
weeks of that they get addicted to it
and then then they got other trouble
okay
but does so
um every time
they
they want to have some alcohol take a
bite out of a keto bar
they're gonna have to work at this but
they do need to take the
uh one healthy brain and heart pack for
100 pounds of body weight get those
nutrients in them and that packet will
go away and it'll be easier for them to
lose a half a pound of two pounds a day
and also um after a while every time
they crave alcohol
uh take another shot of the of the
minerals you know just the plain
plant-derived minerals
okay third and last question
um
butters like almond butter cashew butter
sunflower seed butter
what about those
we know peanut butter is not good
well all those sorts of things do
oxidize if they're not handled properly
and cause problems they can contribute
to hardening of the arteries and all
that kind of stuff okay
they can contribute to the cause of
cancer
so it's not safe to deal with those
unless because you don't know if they've
been sitting on the store shelf for
three months
yes room temperature
you don't know anything about them
all right and so i i kind of avoid all
that stuff the only one that's safe is
butter
you can use cow's butter you can use
sheep butter goat butter llama butter
but butter is the safest one out of all
those
okay a lot of people will pour the oil
off of the top of the almond butter and
go ahead and eat it
but if it's been on this but yeah but
still it'll pour the all off but it's
still got oil in it
you understand
yes
that's my argument
yeah okay well everybody chooses their
um
their choice in life
and so they have to say okay um 25 to 50
more years my kids and grandkids and my
wife or my husband is worth it to me or
to hell with it i'm going to do what i
want and eat what you want and you'll
die 25 years early
yep
that's right
okay
okay thank you
and anita did you did you ask you did
ask a question about your grandson never
mind yes
all right perfect thank you so much and
so i mean sugar in itself can be an
addiction and i know i had an email that
came in
specifically about that where the
grandparents had been giving them
uh
since they were very little with sodas
and icees and slurpees and you know um
which have the
uh phosphoric acid which she expects has
um contributed to her condition of
possibly
from what she's been listening to doctor
nutritional deficiencies because she'd
been getting all the bad stuff and none
of the good stuff
right right and now she's dealing with
tinnitus and osteoporosis of the skull
she does want some recommendations from
you
she is 66 years old
she's been a vegetarian since she was 22
and mostly vegan for the last two years
now with this sugar addiction she
realizes that she may need some
magnesium and mayonnaise but i think she
needs or he needs a lot more than that
right dr yeah okay and she weighs how
much
um he it's a he and
if this person is the person i think he
think it is is to about 240 pounds
at 5 foot 11.
okay all right
yeah people who are sugar addicted is
kind of it's the same thing as alcoholic
addiction
okay
and so when somebody wants to be a vegan
all right be a vegan but i want you to
be a
a
um
let's see here i want you to be an ovo
lacto
uh ovo lacto um pisco vegetarian
what is an ovo lacto-pistol vegetarian
ovo is eggs
uh the only thing in an egg is an animal
is that little one millimeter diameter
white dot on top of the yolk you take
that off say a prayer over it and flush
it down the toilet bearing at sea
the yolk and the white of the egg is
nothing but nutrition think about it in
21 days
that in incubation that little one
millimeter diameter chick will eat all
that yolk and all the white of the egg
and get a heart and a liver and a
kidneys in the brain and the eyes and
digestive system and all the muscles and
the bones and everything there's a lot
of nutrition in that egg
so i want this guy to have three eggs
twice a day only 142 and i have three
eggs twice a day with soft yolks cannabi
cannot be fried cannot be hard boiled
must be soft yolk soft boiled soft yolk
salt poach soft soft soft scrambled
butter
then
uh i want this guy at 240 pounds he's
right at that cusp the finances are not
an issue only have three health
abandoned heart packs a month the full
dose of breakfast lunch and dinner if
finances are an uh
issue do not go lower than two healthy
banana heart packs a full dose of
breakfast and dinner then
i wanted to have
um
two bottles a month of the msm secretary
three breakfast street lunchroom dinner
time and they will support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disc between
the vertebrae bone makes the bone itself
i also want to have the distress
capsules
uh three of those twice it has two
bowels a month
and i want to have our rebounder spore
strength now also um that is of course
we talked about the the ovo the eggs
um and then
the lacto is cheese and milk and that
kind of stuff what's the first food
rebecca whether a whale or a human being
or a giraffe or a rhinoceros or a
porpoise uh or a um gorilla
uh what is the first food of a
newborn baby
mammal
mother's milk
milk milk milk milk cannot be bad for
you okay so anybody who tells you milk
is oh see doctors get after fat
or milk because of the the fat in it no
they said milk fats is going to cause
plaque in your arteries that's crapola
that is not true
you want to be drinking you know
i i eat cheese every meal and i drink
milk
maybe once or twice a day but i have
cheese with every meal
okay if i have a hamburger have cheese
on if i have
our gluten-free pizza which i have three
or four days out of every week
for dinner and our breakfast
i have four different cheeses on it
that's my lacto part and then the pisco
is fish there's no red meat and fish
duh there's no red feet and red meat and
fish so uh two thirds of the mornings i
will have while the last uh river salmon
um
that's smoked
uh and then i also have
um
the uh let's see here the little
fish you know herring and
stuff like that um in
um uh packed in water not oil
and sardines like
packed in water
rather than oil
and so you have your choice
and that way you're not getting all the
bad stuff
but you do need some animal protein
you need some animal minerals and all
that kind of stuff so if you're going to
be a successful vegan you got to be an
ovo lacto pisco vegan
okay
all right thank you so much for that you
still need the supplements
absolutely now we had another question
that came up in regards to gluten-free
flours
are there certain flours that need to be
avoided other than those that contain
gluten
um the flours that need to be avoided
they're made from wheat byron oats are
no such things as gluten free oats they
sell them gluten free oats because
the gluten oats has a different name
it's called gliadin but it's still
gluten
so if it has
gluten-free oat flour in it
no package it up and give it to your
doctor with love you know like the movie
to rush with love
okay yes
you get the drift
definitely now let's go to the next one
let's go to the next standout um dr
wallach and as uh christy is becoming
unmuted i just want to remind everybody
that this program is being brought to
you by
askdoclive.com get back with the person
that invited you to watch this program
whether it's live or the replay doesn't
matter get back with them to get
information on how to order product if
you have never spoken to anybody about
youngevity or the products that dr
wallach is recommending today
feel free to use
askdoclive.com we do have a full store
there available and waiting for you if
you don't know exactly what you need
go ahead and use the contact us and one
of our certified holistic health coaches
will be getting back with you with
information on what you need
specifically for what you're going
through
now we do have a call team as well
um that you can reach out to again is
for those who have never spoken with
anybody else
um in regards to youngevity that number
is eight five five
nine four nine
seven two three four
all right christy
you are on live with dr wallach
hi dr wallach hi
this is just an update i've been on your
program for two months now my original
call was for my optic nerve atrophy
cellophane retinopathy
um
my alternate problem sciatica age spot
is better age spots
are disappearing
um
i feel better i better have a better
mental attitude but i just
my tonight i still have tinnitus and my
optic nerve atrophy
i haven't noticed a difference in that
okay okay how much you weigh
106.
okay and how tall are you
five to
age 71.
okay
all right
none of this is from aging this is all
due to
um
nutritional deficiencies and the fact
that you've gotten some benefit saying
you're absorbing but i want you to
really really make sure that yourself
and your roommates and um
relatives and everybody living in the
same house with you um
need to be drop dead gluten-free no
wheat running around oats they're not
cross-contaminated in the laundry and
the food preparation surfaces the
couches and the beds and you know you
know the drill
and so then um i want you to
make sure
that uh you're taking
the um
let's see here at 106 pounds i want you
to have one healthy brain and heart pack
per month and another bottle of our
slams you can take six of our saline a
day could be two two and two or three
and three whatever is easier for you but
then a half a dose of everything in that
um
except for the selenium uh the half a
dose of everything in that
healthy brain heart pack
at breakfast and have a dose of dinner
time
and then i also i want you to have one
bottle a month
of the because of the sciatica i want
you and the fact that the a spots are
going away that's a good sign
i want you also to take one bottle a
month of our msm saying take three
breakfast three dinner time and they
will support and promote maintenance
repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone makes your bone itself
i also want you to
get some of our cal toddy it does have a
lot of magnesium and some people are
sensitive magnesium if you overdo it
you'll get diarrhea but start out low
somebody who's 106 pounds i always start
out with like i start with just a
teaspoon of the kaltati at breakfast
start out with that and after a week if
you don't have diarrhea or something
like that then go to a teaspoon of
breakfast a teaspoon of dinner time with
the calcite so that one quartz can last
you about three months okay like how
tight it's got extra calcium extra
vitamin d3 extra
collagen that way instead of taking
three products so just take one that's
going to help you a little bit
financially and also just from the
standpoint of convenience okay
then
um
let's see here
uh
i do want you to take one of our eye
products i would go with the vision fx
you go ahead and take two of those
twice a day so one bottle should last
you two months of the vision fx
and so let's go there
and then call us every couple of weeks
we'll walk you through this but all
these things are causing nutritional
deficiency and all these things are
easy to go away
um
the the quickest one will be the
sciatica the tinnitus ringing in the
ears and the ona optic nerve atrophy um
the tinnitus you'll just be walking
along one day and say you know i got it
i don't have that it's an honest anymore
because it'll go it'll go and go and go
and then one
minute
it stops but you got to keep on the
program when it stops you can't stop the
program because within a month or two
you'll be back to where you were
well the one i'm worried about most is
the optic nerve battery
okay well that's also caused by the
skull
uh osteoporosis called squeezing the
optic nerve the optic artery and the
optic vein
because they all have to pass through
the skull from the brain through the
skull to the back of the eye and from
the back of the eye back into the skull
with the optic vein
and all that's getting squeezed just
like your auditory branch of the atrial
nerve is causing being squeezed is
causing it tonight it's raining in the
ears do you have anything going on in
your hands or wrists at all
not anymore
well you did yeah yeah your skull was
squeezing your spine a little bit in my
hand yeah but
not anymore so i know it's working it's
just okay good it's just i'm impatient
okay well thank you for the update and
the test okay thank you but call yeah
call us every couple of weeks because
you're going to have a great testimony
and your story you know chrissy christie
is going to help so many people
thank you
that's fantastic christy i know how good
it feels not to have carpal tunnel
anymore so i'm i'm celebrating with you
on that one for sure
um so dr wallach
the next question is pamela and she says
i'm i'm lactose intolerant at a young
age i was put on dry skim milk by the
doctors is there a difference between
dry milk and regular milk
yeah regular milk is a liquid and dry
milk is a powder
as far as nutritionally oh oh
i don't think there's as much fat
in the in the dry milk
i think they have scooped off the fat
okay yeah most of the time non-fat dry
milk and it's that good fat that we need
well the good fat has vitamin a and d
and e in it
and so you're not getting vitamin a d
and e
in the dry milk
because it's it's these are fat soluble
vitamins so when you when you pour and
when you skim off the fat you're
skimming off those fat soluble vitamins
yes okay so thank you so much for that
and next i want to see if we can get
charlotte
um to come on with us
so charlotte had a neuroma and it was
very painful she wants to know what
vitamins
she needs but she had surgery to have
the neuroma removed a year ago
where was his neuroma located
well i'm as i'm reading here that's one
of the questions that i don't see the
answer to that i know is very important
so
okay well let's let's
yeah so here
charlotte is here with us dr wallach so
charlotte please go ahead dr walk has
some questions for you and let's get
them answered
okay
okay where's this aroma located as on a
foot or a hand or an elbow or shoulder
my right foot
between the
third metatarsal
okay
now do you have anything going on in
your low back do you have any sciatica
on your low back
no sciatica
i have a little pain once in a while
lately but that's it
okay low back a little bit
are you coloring your hair wearing a wig
or is that your this is a cap i'm just
cold i got a warm cap on and i do color
my hair yes
okay so you do have some you know gray
or white or silver in your hair yes you
have any varicose veins or hemorrhoids
uh no
no spider veins nothing no
okay what do you weigh
154 i'm 5 foot 10 and i'm 65.
okay do you have any issues how about
pressure diabetes
um
i have uh colon problems i've had
ulcerative colitis
okay
and then do you have any skin issues at
all
no
do you have any tinnitus ringing in the
ears no
balance problems or vertigo dizziness
no
okay good
um
no afib no heart problems
uh i had a two years ago two and a half
years ago i had a my heart we had a
murmur i had the
the strands that had to be re
um
redone repaired
on my
mitral valve
okay so they did an open heart surgery
or they do it through the veins and they
did open heart surgery it was awful
okay and so it was a valve problem
yes it was a leaky valve
okay so that means your heart was big
and the valve leaves weren't meeting
properly okay
okay so you had an enlarged heart
which is a nutritional deficiency
all right so um here we go you get rid
of all the bad foods you know this but
this is also for the rest of the
listeners who are hearing your story so
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat by ryan notes
no sugar no carbohydrate or drinks
uh and even the diet one's got to go 154
pounds you're right on that cost because
you had heart surgery i'd have you take
two healthy brain and heart packs for a
month a full dose everything twice a day
once you get two bottles a month for
msm's you can take three at breakfast
three at lunch three dinner time and
they're going to support and promote
managed repair of heart valves
um cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between a
vertebrae bone makes bone itself
blood vessel walls arteries and
veins and so forth um then
i also want you to have our vitamin d3
take go ahead take three of those twice
a day it's two bottles a month
and let's see here
i do want you to
obviously the colon thing i want you to
have
our killer biotic take three of those
twice a day that's the rishi mushrooms
and six other mushrooms in there that
are anti-inflammatory and pain relieving
but it's imperative you stay away from
the gluten there's all these all these
issues either directly to or secondary
to gluten
problems
okay
and
this is all resolvable
um when you're here
problem
um
let's see here uh it wouldn't hurt to go
ahead and take three of our hair skin
and nails take three of those twice a
day that's two vowels a month and that
will speed up the hair color coming back
um and uh that tells you
because it's a red warning signal that
you know you've already had a heart
issue uh you we don't want an aneurysm
and you're rupturing your brain and your
heart your ar and stuff like that and so
you really need to do all this stuff
because you've already been warned and
you survived it which is a miracle and
so we want to not fall backwards okay
okay
go ahead could i ask one more thing
whenever about two and a half years ago
i was raking some leaves and
um
something like clicked and my body and
my right side of my body like
gradually
down the center the right side i have
this peripheral coldness
and it seems like it comes from my foot
from the neuroma and it's i'm freezing
cold like most of the time it and i
look it goes the other direction because
have you shrunk any in height
uh i don't know
what happens is as you get degenerative
just the vertebrae get closer together
they smash the roots of the spinal
nerves that originate from your lumbar
area your low back and they go down your
legs and so when those nerves get
pinched
as they're leaving your spinal cord to
go down your leg they get pinched you
get all these peripheral neuropathy
symptoms you get cold you get tingling
numbness pain and all this kind of stuff
and it comes and goes and be different
um you have um
hammer toes and all kinds of weird stuff
going on
and people want to treat the foot but
it's really the back
you understand
okay and it can just be one side like
yeah oh yeah absolutely
okay um yeah it can be one side um it's
kind of like everything else uh
you can have neuropathy in one foot and
hammer toe in one foot and the other
foot is okay
yeah um because
when you shrink when your just shrinks
it doesn't shrink
symmetrically it might shrink more on
one side than the other so you have more
things going on that side where it's
shrinking more okay okay
but it's a good question very good
question
thank you you're very welcome okay
all right thank you so much shirla for
coming on with that now
um you had gone a little bit into hair
loss but we also have a question in
regards to
hair loss
that is that could be associated with
hypothyroidism
now i don't have any specifics other
than
female um so if you were working with
somebody that had hypothyroidism and was
experiencing lots of hair loss
at a hundred pounds doctor were like
what would be the recommendation
okay first we want to get rid of
what's got all the bad foods get rid of
the bathrooms okay and of course age has
nothing to do with it
all right
and so you have to appreciate
that
when you're deficient in nutrients it's
going to cause you thyroid issues the
odds are your deficient other nutrients
that can cause other problems so it may
not be directly related to the thyroid
issue
all right
and so at 100 pounds with thyroid issues
for hair well i take people that have
been like a bowling bowl i mean no hair
like bowling ball for 40 years and three
weeks time they're starting to grow back
here and in three months time they got a
full head of hair again after 40 years
of no hair
this is very it works every time
so none of the bad foods as you said
and then hundred pounds going to have
the big hammer out of the toolbox and
one healthy brand heart pack get another
bottle of our slimes there's one bottle
of slime in the healthy banana hard
packs i want to get another bottle of
slime so i can take six a day three at
breakfast three dinner time or at 100
pounds say two two and two
then they need the hair skin and nails
i'm gonna take three of those twice a
day
and then
i would also
have them take
the
fucoid z take three of those twice a day
two pounds a month and the ocean's gold
take it from the other ocean take three
of those twice a day be two balls a
month so that'll take care of all issues
including the thyroid issues
and the hair issues
okay
all right perfect and since we're
talking about here dr wallach yvonne got
her hair analysis back and now she she
doesn't know how to read all the
information could you give us some
recommendations there on how to get
information about reading your hair
analysis well the nice thing about it
they have these
what should i say
um presentations in there and they have
these live horizontal lines and it shows
you if you get down below this
horizontal line that means you're not
absorbing very much there's two
horizontal lines from about 25 percent
up from the bottom and 25
down from the top if your numbers for
the various minerals are in there you're
good
if you for instance sometimes will be
the calcium
and the magnesium are just off the roof
and doctors oh you can't take any more
calories you're taking too much calcium
that doctor should be put in jail what's
happening is the parathyroid glands are
pulling more calcium out of the bones
because you're significantly severely
calcium deficient and the parathyroid
glands are overreacting and pulling so
much calcium out is showing up in the
hair analysis
okay it's not that you're supplementing
with too much calcium is your
parathyroid glands are overworking
okay so don't quit taking calcium tell
the doctor to go to you know where and
get another doctor all right because
that doctor doesn't know how to read
laboratory work
they should suspend his license until he
goes back to school he or she
okay
and then
um
there's another
graph which shows toxic metals and the
same thing is true you want all the
toxic metals to be below that
bottom line and not even showing up at
all is best
as long as they're below that bottom
line they're not into levels that are
going to impact you but once you get
above that first bottom line and you
start seeing the
you know
lead mercury arsenic all that kind of
stuff above the bottom line that means
you got to work at it
and what you do
is um
you get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no also
glutens and wheat brown rhinos so you
can absorb stuff
and then you do a detox
you do the 90s nutrients the healthy
brain and heart pack and then i would
throw in
the herbal rainforest 13 cleansing herbs
okay
and
um 78 minerals
herbal rainforest
and take two doses a day and then three
months later do another hair analysis
you will see that all those toxic
minerals are dropping which is good
and so i do a hair analysis once a year
because i travel so much and who knows
what you're going to pick up in the
local foods and you know around the
world and so forth so i do a hair
analysis once a year
and because
i
have you know my little
business model
that my youngevity business
will pay for my health insurance my
youngest business will pay for my hair
analysis my special dietary needs
including all my supplements they're all
tax deductible
yeah it's fabulous it's fabulous and
when you go on trips and you meet with
distributors you can write off the trip
legitimately right off the trip
absolutely
ah yes it's awesome awesome well we are
at the top of the hour dr wallach and
on behalf of myself and jonty mccollier
and nassema omar and ruth ellen sanchez
we are honored and we are
so thankful that you are able to take
this two hours and
be with us be a resource that we can
share with others
and please everybody
share
this program with others
get with the person that invited you
get the information and the ordering
options that you need in order to get
what you
can feed your body with confidence
that it's getting the nutrients it needs
so it can thrive
again my name is rebecca kozak you are
watching ask doc live
and we are here for you
bye for now bye bye god bless
bye